in this lesson you're going to learn how
to go from the standard form of the
quadratic equation to the vertex form of
a quadratic equation and we're going to
get there by completing the square and
we're gonna do three examples we're
gonna start off with an easy example
with that leading coefficient is one a
little bit more challenging example
where that leading coefficients not one
but it's an integer and then a more
difficult one where that leading
coefficient is negative and a fraction
so let's start off with the first one y
equals x squared plus 6x minus 8 what do
you do to complete the square well the
first step is you want to get that
constant that number on the other side
of the equation with the Y so to do that
what we're going to do is we're just
going to add 8 to both sides of the
equation that's going to give us Y plus
8 equals x squared plus 6x and when you
complete the square it's easier if that
leading coefficient that number in front
of the x squared is 1 in this case it is
so the next thing we want to do is we
want to look at that number that's in
front of X we want to take half that
number and square it so you want to take
6 divided by 2 and square it that's
going to be 9 I usually like to do the
work a little bit off to the side if I
add 9 out of thin air right just I'm
adding 9 over here I have to add 9 to
the other side of the equation to keep
it balanced okay so we don't want to
change the equation we just want to
change the way that it looks so this
comes out to Y plus 17 equals x squared
plus 6x plus 9 now what we've done is
we've created a perfect square trinomial
and you can factor this easily by taking
half of this middle coefficient and it's
the quantity squared now if this was
minus 6x this would be minus 3 and you
can check your work you just have to
write x plus 3 times X plus 3 and foil
and you'll see that you get back this
original trinomial here that's just kind
of like a shortcut so now all we have is
y plus 17 equals x plus 3 squared we
want to get Y by itself so we're just
going to subtract 17 from both sides of
the equation and so that gives us y
equals the quantity X plus 3 squared
minus 17 and now you can see that it's
in this form right here
the
vertex is going to be the opposite of
positive 3 that's negative 3 and this is
going to be negative 17 so that's our
vertex the a value is positive once we
know the parabola is going to open up
and you've got it okay number two now
we've got y equals two x squared minus
eight X plus one notice we have that
leading coefficient a which is not equal
to one so this is a little bit more
challenging but the first step is we
want to get the constant this number on
the other side with the Y so just
subtract one we've got Y minus one
equals two times x squared minus 8x now
the next step is I'm going to factor out
this two out of both of these terms so
it's just like doing the distributive
property backwards or factoring out or
dividing out two and what I'd like to do
is I like to leave a little space here
for completing the square so what you
want to do is you want to take this
coefficient the number in front of the
ax you want to divide it by two and
square it so that's negative four
divided by two is negative two negative
two squared is positive four I'm going
to add four here but the here is where
students sometimes go a little bit off
the tracks they say hmm if I edit four
here Mario don't add four over here but
because this is inside of the
parenthesis this four it's actually two
times four so really out of thin air
we're adding eight to the right side of
the equation we have to add eight to the
left side of the equation so that's
going to give us Y plus seven equals two
and then now we're going to factor this
and it's a perfect square
perfect trinomial here and so we're
gonna write it as a binomial squared and
remember it's always half of that middle
coefficient so this is going to be X
minus two the quantity squared if this
was x squared plus four X then it would
be X plus two the quantity squared now
we're almost there we want to get Y by
itself so let's just subtract seven from
both sides of the equation and we get y
equals two times X minus two squared
minus seven and you can see now the
vertex is going to be at positive two
this one's the opposite negative seven
this one's the same a value is positive
two that two is gonna stretch the
parabola making a little bit narrower
and it's going to open up because it's
positive and you've got it Before we
jump into number three if we haven't met
yet in your
to the channel my name is Mario from
Mario's math tutoring and what I do is I
tutor students full-time but what I do
is I take what I learned from working
with my students and I try to condense
it down and take the simplest and the
best way of explaining some of these
problems so that I can share them with
you so you can get the benefit too and
my goal for the channel is to really you
know make learning math less stressful
so you can raise your grade pass your
class and go on to pursue your dreams
and so that's what we're all about here
let's go into the last problem and I
want to really show you how to complete
the square with these more difficult
ones and again that first step is you
want to subtract 3 from both sides of
the equation okay and the reason you're
doing that is you're just trying to get
that number out of the way okay so that
you can complete the square a little bit
more easily so now we're left with
because these cancel is negative 1/2 x
squared minus 4x you don't want that
leading coefficient to be something
other than one it makes it difficult to
complete the square so what I like to do
is I like to factor out the leading
coefficient and when you factor
something out it's really like dividing
it out so you're it's like dividing out
negative one half but what we do is we
put that negative 1/2 in front of the
parenthesis like this this is going to
cancel that's going to give us x squared
remember when you divide by a fraction
it's like multiplying by the reciprocal
so this is really like multiplying by
negative two which is going to give us
positive 8x and then I like to leave a
little space for completing the square
now if you're not sure if you did it
right you can always distribute the
negative 1/2 that's gonna give you a
negative 1/2 x squared negative 1/2
times 8x gives you back the negative 4x
and you can see it matches so you know
you're on the right track and then now
when we complete the square we say
what's half of this middle coefficient
squared so I like to do that work a
little bit off on the side here 8
divided by 2 is 4 and then 4 squared is
16 now if I add 16 to the right you're
probably saying well Mario you have to
add 16 to the left but because it's in
parenthesis it's actually negative 1/2
times 16 that's like negative 8 then
again we're adding out of thin air
negative 8 to the right side we have to
add negative 8 to the left side to keep
the equation balanced we don't want to
change you know the overall equation we
just want to change the way that it
looks we just want to change the form so
now
this is a perfect square we can factor
it and it's going to factor 2x plus 4
the quantity squared remember it's
always half of that middle coefficient
if this was negative 8x I would write
negative for the last step you want to
get Y by itself so I'm just going to add
11 to both sides of the equation and
that gives us y equals negative 1/2 the
quantity X plus 4 squared plus 11 so our
vertex is going to be at negative 4
positive 11 and the a value is negative
which means it opens down the 1/2 is
going to make the graph wider so it's
like a vertical shrink or vertical
compression and you got it the other
thing that you learn about when you're
doing this completing the square is
solving equations by completing the
square and I talked about that in that
video right there so follow me over
there to get some more practice with
completing the square and solving
equations by completing the square
I'll see you in that video